ヒカキンさん
チャンネル登録出す
1000万人
俺じゃございまーさーん
[音楽]
ああああああ
ああ
[音楽]
持っていません
部屋が終わったいや本当におめでとう
ございました銀座
改めましてこんにちははじめ冊ようです
今日9月の10日今日は歴史が動いた日で
ございます私の事務所の先輩であるそして
人生の先輩でもそして youtube と
しての先輩でもあるヒカキンさんが
チャンネル登録者数が1000万人突破し
ましてあめでとう思います
早すぎません親分尾山速過ぎません俺
なんか抜かれたのつい先日なんですけども
そこからも本当に意味がわからない息を
いるの見ててええそんな所でいきますって
いう衝撃的な速さで言ったっていうのは
あのそのような買うそうですねいやーもう
8月の日か気にさも凄すぎますし何だろう
僕もいつを一緒にチャンネル登録者数
1000万人を目指してたんですけども
もうすぐな母というと凄すぎましたあの人
はもちろん良きライバルでありたいと思う
んですけどもやっぱりー
ヒカキンさんには敵わないの動画が抜かれ
たとか悔しいとかそういう感動じゃなくて
素直に課金さんっていう村ゲーしてる人が
チャンネル登録者数1000万に辿り着い
たって言うのは本当にうれしくて何かお
めでとうございますて感動ももちろんなん
ですけども
音がすごい
親分の裏で
努力打ってとなんだかを見てきてたんで
なんかその嬉しい釣り感動みたいな肝臓が
すごいですねまぁやったんですごいんです
よ皆さん
競らないと思いますの女っす努力してます
からね知ってると思いますけどそれ以上に
努力してますよの人はヤフーとの撮影で1
回陥ったときもあったんですけどもう動画
撮影会でもずっと動画の修正とかこれをを
したいとかという話をずっとされてたりし
て本当の真面目に真剣に動画に取り組んで
いらっしゃる方がね香満を持して
1000万円以下れたっていうのは本当に
を買ううれしい悔しいって感情を抜かれる
ときにありましたけど1000万人という
その大台に到達したっていうのは本当に僕
は嬉しいですしそれを見て僕もちょっとお
皿2貫ばなきゃなと思いました電話してみ
ましょうか
あもしもし
ああ
お疲れさまでぜひと傷をつけそうでしょ
コメントとかもいやいや知らせ先ほどご
挨拶できるに妄想です
なんかずっとしてる奴生
会えなかったけど a
高木さん改めてチャンネル登録者数は
1,000万人おめでとうございます
誰でゲイ動画撮ってるこれをとってます
位掛けた本当おめでとうございますなんか
も
生放送で行った時まず普通に泣きそうです
と僕
ああありがとう a
事務所いたらしいでもねああああ寝過ごし
の仕事してました戦犯の人がもうすぐ
ムードうーん
1日毎例題をつくってくれてすごいなぁ
それはまっさー日の昼に行ってしまうと
いいんですか見ちゃう真昼間ですよねし
たかったそうなんですよ
ヒカキンさん1000万に行かれたいまの
率直な感想は
いやーでもなんか
実感があってっ
これは
謝っとくわ先に感想等が今後動きと彼は僕
のチャンネルで話すことがないんです今回
はピカ236つかぜひ話された方がいいと
思うので釣れず感謝の言葉を脱ぎますで
また伝えさせていただきましたいやー
やっぱまずすごいって早いよそのスピード
は信じられ本当にすごかったよ8月とか
もう動画も理由わからないですしそもそも
あの方もともと多分 youtube 以外
にもやんなきゃいけない事とか色々お仕事
があると思うんですけどそんなんよく本当
にやってるなと思ってさせかなと思って8
月は見ておりますだってさぁ俺が抜かれた
と思ったらすぐも1000万円
バンディットいたさん8月ですごいよ
あの僕が終わってるとかそういうわけじゃ
ないですか俺も一1ヶ月で145万人
ぐらい増えてるんでなんかも俺がすごい
ヘボいとかじゃなくて日か聞いたが凄
すぎるっていうだけの話な気がしますあの
ううーんに入らせていただいてから同じ
事務所としていろんなお仕事をご一緒にさ
せて頂いてきましたしチャンネル登録者数
がヒカキンさんより僕のが上の時から
ずっとヒカキンさんのことを蓮園に尊敬し
ています今後はそれは二度と変わることは
ないなと思っていますじゃあ何か
感動しました本当にらず動いよ本当に
1000万人って俺も1対4がう素直に
そう思った一日でした今日はこれを直接
絶えずに you to bar らしく
動画で伝えますは100均さんに旋盤に
本当におめでとうございます俺は
一生比嘉恵さんについていきますその謙虚
さとか努力とかいろんな見ながら部分が
あるんですけどもまずはしっかりと語訳に
ついていくようにチャンネル登録者数で
しっかりと日か聞いたの後1000万匂い
たいと思います頑張りますが本当に
持ちかけてこんなに頑張っている方が
いらっしゃる中で頑張れない奴いうルーム
ということいますね頑張ります本当いつも
動画を見てくださる皆さん視聴者さんあっ
ての肇社長ですいつもありがとう多い
抜こうとは思えませんが追いかけようと
思います
井山よくば追い越し出すよあわよくば
追い越しますけどまずはしっかり1000
万人目指して頑張って行きたいと思います
がにいさん本当におめでとうございます
同じ事務所のクリエイターとして自分では
でつけばヒカキンさんの割と近くにいる
クリエーターとしてチャンネル登録者数的
にも近くにいるクリエイターとしてそして
心から尊敬している先輩のクリエイターと
して今日は心からお湯をやさせていただき
ましたおめでとうございます
[音楽]
あたを応用に親分の後大ように私肇社長も
頑張りますというふうに皆さんよかったら
チャンネル登録の方よろしくお願いします
お祀りしております登録お願いってね普段
なかなか言えないんですけどめっちゃして
ほしいからねあた次回の動画でお会いし
ましょうじゃあなお姉ちゃーん
[音楽]
ブーバーし